ancien premier adjoint derrière pierre
c'est l'un court avant de passer dans
l'opposition en montant une première
liste citoyenne 2002 gérard morfin
présente à nouveau une liste citoyenne
pour les élections de 2020 il faut
maintenant quand on parle de démocratie
la vivre il a partagé et ça fait partie
de cet axe là de cette idée là que même
une campagne électorale peut avoir des
concepts citoyens une liste est un
programme qui seront révélés au fur et à
mesure mais déjà la volonté d'établir
des référents par quartier pour une
meilleure représentativité de la commune
trois d'entre eux ont été présentés
comme aïcha nedjari une ancienne élue de
la majorité
moi je vais le quartier d'ordi parc
pourquoi parce que pendant de nombreuses
années j'ai été présidente de
l'association des locataires
puis c'est pour ça que gérard est venu
me chercher pour être représentante de
ce quartier qui me tient qui me tient à
coeur et pouvoir le proposer et
n'ouvrira à d'autres quartiers de la
verrière qui sont vraiment cloisonné
aujourd'hui pas d'étiquette politique la
liste tient à son identité citoyenne
pour vivre et partager la démocratie je
fais pas politically jamais fait
politique et je suis pas là pour faire
de la politique est comme jarre et dans
ce top 6 heures et les gens sont dans
cette optique là et aujourd'hui c'est ça
l'idée citoyenne c'est un acteur de sa
vie et pouvoir apporter quelque chose
pour l'heure les 31 non nécessaires ne
figure pas sur la liste mais sont en
voie de l'être dans la commune de la
verrière trois autres listes sont
aujourd'hui déclaré